lady magic was her nickname when she
played back in the day now she is with
the Sacramento Kings organization still
correct me I am NOT my I resigned my mom
is sick she's been living in Florida and
to get from Sac was so Florida life
choice and the right choice got it so
you were an assistant with the
Sacramento Kings for a bit and now you
are the new head coach of the Power Team
power head coach of the big three
good to see you Nancy Lieberman thank
you I'm really it's very thankful for
ice cube and for Clyde thinking enough
about me to ask me to coach him there
later when they give you a ring when
they call you up for this okay my life
is crazy as is yours about four weeks
ago I'm on my couch I'm watching the
NCAA tournament I'm going back and forth
I'm watching straight out of Compton and
all of a sudden my phone rings and it's
Clyde Drexler and he goes hey girl and
he starts explaining and he goes you
know I ski we'd like to hire you to
replace me cuz he had just gone to the
commissioner ship right he's gonna be
great at that cuz he's just a very very
high IQ very even-keeled guy right with
a ton of respect
tons of respect right and you know you
try to wiggle out a story from the dream
team and he just shut that down I try to
get something from him
he's political yeah he's good like that
yeah so I'm really happy to be out there
with the guys you know I'm doing TV
right now for the pelicans so I know you
had Lillard and I'm getting ready for
the game tomorrow so it's gonna be a
great series well I mean let's say I
guess let's hit that a little bit since
you just brought that up and then we'll
circle back to the big three when
cousins goes down everybody thought
that's a wrap that's a nice attempt of
the pelicans to try and put their own
super team together but Anthony Davis
has been just out of his mind there was
what that two three week stretch when he
was damn near averaging believable 50
and 20 you mean he had some wilt like
numbers he was putting up for a while
there what what are their chances you
think in the second season against
Damian Lillard trailblazers we just
well the the the Blazers kind of limped
into the playoffs you know they lost for
their last five and the pelicans and
they won five in a row I mean they beat
San Antonio they beat the Clippers they
beat Golden State but you could see this
real cool aura in the locker room and
there's a chemistry there you never know
how you get it you never know how you
lose it
Anthony has taken his game to another
level but I'd like to also besides his
superstardom
talk about what drew Holliday did and
Roseanne Rondo he was recruited to that
team by DeMarcus Cousins Acra mento for
two years he is savant like Rondo he's
unbelievable he gets a really bad rap
they love him teams come in and teams
that he's been traded from coaches
players they want to hug him say hi to
him
there's a misconception about him so why
does he get because he's smarter than
you and you don't like it you better
show up at practice the next day as a
player or a coach knowing your stuff
mm-hmm because he's got that Rain Man
kind of thing going and he'll call you
out on it and quite frankly you don't
want to be embarrassed he's amazing and
look what he's done everybody writes him
off and he's had a great you know
stretch leading this team to the plan
yeah I would say Nancy Lieberman here in
the rich I enjoy saying you over there
Chris that the three sixes that the
three six matchups in both conferences
Sixers heat and this one trailblazers
and pelicans definitely interest me here
you know more than many of the first
round matchups that we're seeing it's
gonna be good well what do you think who
wins at all eventually well I believe
that Newark itch has to play a big part
for the Blazers to move on because
between Lillard and McCallum those guys
averaged 48 and a half points a game so
if you can slow them down and do holiday
he might be that best two-way defender
since Kawhi Leonard he's really good and
deshante Murray he's in that
conversation as a two-way you know I can
I can lock you down defensively but if
they don't get help around that those
two the pelicans they're spreading the
wealth right now they're getting four or
five guys in double figures they were
getting
41 points off their bench and for me the
magic number is 110 if the Pels can get
up around 110 points a game
you're not going to outscore them well
ask the poll question of Nancy Lieberman
while we're on the subject of the NBA
right here yeah Nancy which three or
four seed is the best chance to win the
title so looking at Sixers Cavs Blazers
Thunder I'm gonna say the Sixers because
I think the Sixers are gonna beat the
Cavs I was saying I said when Kyrie went
down that had opened the door for the
Sixers absolutely look at us whoo I mean
in in our world of basketball
you need a Batman and a Robin and
another superhero who is that with
Cleveland and let me tell you I admire
LeBron James for what he's done on the
court how he handles himself off the
court he's I never thought I'd under the
words that he is in that Michael Jordan
there's a quality there the Kobe level
yes because it's ridiculous and it's the
mindset of winning and the preparation
of how you get there physically 82 games
is amazing mm-hm it really is especially
at 33 years old but the Sixers if the
Sixers do they need embiid to pull that
off though do you think yes okay yes
they do so they're playing well I mean
this kid Simmons is out of his mind
16 in row we've got Brett Brown coming
up in our number three he's a brilliant
coach he's really good also well Mikey
came out of the pop system the pop tree
yeah the pop tree and you just learn a
discipline of how you gonna do things
like over and over and over again
nothing happens by happenstance and then
you know they brought in the two great
shooters we had Belinelli in Sacramento
and JJ Redick you must have snipers and
they have snipers on that team you've
got you know Simmons you know I think
it's gonna be co-working of the Year by
the way first time since kid and Grant
Hill right was it mm we discussed that
just the other day that
was that it was a tie then in you know
five right 94 90 it was in the 90s right
yeah I was in Detroit 94 we all are
they're catching up to us know is funny
that that so Simmons technically you
know Donovan Mitchell says he's not a
rookie you know yeah and I'm getting a
shirt that says I'm not old
I like it
hey let me take a 60-second break we
come back we'll talk some more big three
and again I know you live in the Dallas
area and and have come across DES I'm
sure and there's some big news I've got
better man you got better Nancy
Lieberman all right is here on the Rich
Eisen show back in 60 seconds
Nancy Lieberman jr. on the Rich Eisen
show just called Delta phone Brockman my
snipers well del two four ways a town
like that so that's the villain le right
and Brockman would love to evens have
two seconds of jayjay Reddick's outside
seconds in his life
jayjay read it would love to have my out
okay I'm gonna have to say no well you
know Chris's Chris can get you know
antes never seen the jumper well I mean
like also like Rondo Chris can get
triggered from time to time you know you
can get under his skin you can get him
off his game he can trigger him a little
bit oh my god so we can't make it
personal I play better when I'm angry
did you ever play better when you were
angry I was always angry actually
growing up because of my childhood no
father no food no heat no electricity
people used to say wide why was I so
mean on the court I actually played
angry my whole life I used to beat the
crap out of my teammates at Old Dominion
and I'm now actually this is true sadly
I have reached out to teammates that I
just annihilated every day and just to
say hey man I'm sorry you know I didn't
mean to do that
how do they respond when you said they
couldn't believe it because I was every
day every practice every drill was like
it was the championship game you came
across the lane BAM I I mean it was
maybe that New Yorker in me but my
childhood in me and I just had so much
pent up that I and I we didn't have dr.
Phil or Oprah to walk us through that
moment of her life right
and I I needed sports more than sports
needed me football was my first sport
baseball was my best sport and
basketball changed my life
baseball was your best best sport I
could have played on our high school
baseball team yes
men's baseball team yeah I just ended a
play softball
what your game was you cuz I stopped
short stop dead range yes were you did
you have any pop jet pop yes very good
it's crazy right
you know that it's not crazy I don't put
anything past you nothing zero I've
known you for a very long time and we've
mentioned in the television only segment
Dion's
on you forever in a day you're tight
with him yes and he he sings your
praises all the time well it's one of
the the the ollie thing in my life was
he told me and he was my lifelong friend
and mohammed told me when I was 19 you
know respect everybody but fear nobody
and I've lived by that my whole life
when did you meet him first I fell in
love with Muhammad when I was 10 I saw
this man and he changed my life and then
I met him at 19 and he must have known I
was kind of broken a little bit on the
inside and he said they'll never be a
day you go in your life without me and
he was dead that to you when I was 19
with my mom it was amazing and every big
thing that has happened to me in my life
Muhammad was on the phone and and just
there for me he taught me about life
philanthropy racism you know just taking
the hit he goes you're gonna have to
fight sometimes I'm like like fight
fight he goes you might have to fight
and he goes you can play against men you
can play against women
people are gonna profile you and you
have to you have to love you write the
greatest love of all mm-hmm I decided
long ago never to walk in anyone's
shadow if I fail if I succeed at least I
live as I believe no matter what you
take from me you can't take away my
dignity because the greatest love of all
hmm is inside of me he he gave me that
I'm so grateful Nancy Lieberman here on
the Rich Eisen show so Dez you know him
at all pretty well okay in Dallas what
do you what do you think of this Nancy
now that jared has him in and says we're
done essentially you know Jerry's very
loyal to guys almost to a fault and I
know the buzz in Dallas was that the
consensus in the media was to let DES go
because he was targeted so much bye-bye
dak and it there was just no connection
there and you have to have that
especially with a young quarterback and
dropping passes couldn't have that
separation that he had early in his
career
look they traded Babe Ruth and they
traded Gretzky and they can let Dez
Bryan go if he's not performing at the
level that the animal
Linux say and the that the the I says
it's gonna be very emotional for for DES
I know it already is what did you say he
said he I'm gonna see him twice a year
he said to reporters when he left the
star
he's on kind of a tweet binge right now
saying that he's sorry for all the
tweets but it's very personal for him
are you concerned is how he's gonna tell
me again you you know him you live in
the Metroplex and then how long have you
been in Dallas now 38 okay so you've
been around there you know the
organization you know Jerry they have
your woven into the fabric of that
sports part of the town are you
concerned about how he's gonna handle
this right now he's gonna vent and with
no filter but then if I were with DES I
would say why the hell didn't you feel
this when you were with the Cowboys why
weren't you angry every day and come
into practice every day to get better
why didn't you have this when you had
that now now you're gonna use it to fuel
your next level of your career we're
paid professionals we should come every
day with that type of focus and wanting
to be better you don't think he was uh
well obviously his production went down
and we're in a production business if I
don't play well you get to cut me if I
play well you get to pay me I like that
part of the program and you it's it's
how you bring it every day and he might
not have brought it every day cuz he
didn't produce at the level that he had
and now you're gonna bring this to the
big three Nancy Lieberman I'm looking at
your team here Corey Maggette II is your
captain you got Dookie right there is
your captain he's great man
Cuttino Mobley who I met a few years ago
good dude
smart sharp competitive okay Glen big
baby Davis is your co-captain he is one
of our co-captain well I talked to him
the other night I did ask him about you
know how he was doing that we were very
supportive of him that's America you're
innocent until proven guilty and I did
recommend that he lay off the Kentucky
Fried Chicken or Popeyes I did throw
that out there that was so funny take
that you know coach yeah I'm like
I'm actually serious about the fried
chicken what about the briefcase I said
if you have any left we could use it for
the team okay he's good he's he's good
I'm looking forward to coaching him you
know we got Q Richardson we needed a
shooter we got Q he looks fantastic and
we signed birdman' birdman you drafted
right you you've drafted him last night
right there first our first pick number
four yeah so I was on the phone with him
and he he's an amazing guy he's a winner
he's tough he's strong he's competitive
he's got a ring mm-hmm he knows what it
takes to win
so who your snipers here Corinne Quinton
q Korie q and Cuttino there they're good
they were you know Cuttino told me
yesterday they were two possessions away
from getting to the finals last year
mm-hmm Cena tell me what happened in the
possessions but this this is really
really high-level basketball you know we
all grew up playing one-on-one two one
two three and three no matter where we
started right we might not had gym you
have to have a high IQ there's a lot of
strategy you might not be able to go you
know 50 by 94 anymore and have all that
athleticism but in three on three it's
about execution it's about skill and
will and this league has gone up
exponentially
I mean Ice Cube I'm sure was just amazed
at all the talent that this leaves gonna
have this year and there's you know 10
12 15 thousand people coming to the game
oh yeah we need to see the legendary the
Hall of Famers great players that you
admired I'm very thankful by the way to
Rick Barry he invited me to the game in
Dallas last year and he says no you know
what sit on the bench with me and I was
like okay
there was 16,000 people in Dallas it was
such a family atmosphere it's a cultural
changer I mean I saw LL Cool J I met Ice
Cube I'm like why the two L's together
that was a whole nother situation
I'm very inquisitive about stuff like
you are but I'm proud to be part of the
big three and what we're doing to extend
players careers
competitiveness and it's an Olympic
sport now so it's no joke certain
there's no joke correct it's gonna
happen I believe also in college
basketball I think they're gonna go and
have a three-on-three element in the
future well I
I love having you on Nancy anytime
please let me know whenever you're in
the neighborhood these doors are always
open and I miss chatting with you thank
you it's been an honor thank you for
having stopped come on I love you and
I'm proud of you right back at you
right back at you at Nancy Lieberman on
Twitter and check out again the big
three when it comes near you it's tall
starts June 22nd in Houston Texas
wait good luck with power good luck with
power thank you if you're in an area
bring the kids that we went last year to
Staples it was awesome
kids loved it well if you want fineness
come percent the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience